you have such a passion for filmmaking
yet you combine that passion with your
work for social justice tell us about
that I grew up in Washington DC and
actually Falls Church Virginia suburb
outside and one of our neighbors a
wonderful woman named Mary Ann hurt who
I love very much was a grand doyen of
northern virginia democratic politics at
the time and yes there are Democrats in
Northern Virginia and she got me
involved in my first campaign when I was
four years old and I had the bug I would
go out with her door to door as I admit
slightly precocious four year old it was
a candidate running for supervisor I
have a very nice thank you note from
Allen magazine thanking me for my
campaigning and so I I grew up as kind
of a political junkie right from the
time I was a kid the Watergate hearings
happened while I was in junior high
school and my mom let me stay home from
school and watch them because she saw
that it was something I was deeply
interested in and she had a hunch that I
would learn at least as much from
watching the trials as I would from my
public junior high school in Northern
Virginia's classes that week so politics
had always been a real love of mine and
sort of turned into a lot of it
formulated from my time at Yale into a
love for social activism as well great
thank you